Tyler is in Harrisburg Virginia hi Tyler
welcome today Ramsey show hey Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
a quick question
all be done was set to at the beginning
of October and I'm getting married in
April good for you though thank you
so we unfortunately got in a wreck and
nothing seriously but the insurance
company totaled out her car so
unfortunately we or her depending on
your answer for this have a car payment
so my question is do I get started on my
three sorry she hold her car to the
insurance company not pay for her car oh
yeah they cut her a check for it yeah so
what is our money was she debt-free
before yeah we had that conversation and
I've chimed in as much as I could but I
didn't win that one and they cut her a
check for like forty two hundred and
that was what her car was worth yet and
she went in debt to buy a nicer car so
let me help you understand this you got
to be real careful she did not go into
car debt because of the rack
she went into card app because she
bought a nicer car than she had before
yeah I'm aware of that make sure you
understand what's really going on all
right yeah how much car how much card
debt does she have I think it's about
$18,000 115
yeah yeah so she went from a four
thousand dollar car to a twenty four
thousand dollar car correct yeah we both
had no no car payments and until that
happened we were working on saving up
for and then yeah all right how can I
help sooner rather than later so my
question is do I since where you're
getting married and becoming one in
April do I just go ahead and start
helping tackle her tackle that debt with
her because I'm going to inherit it
no she ain't stole it are it's my car
she can't work what is her income she's
an x-ray tech so she's probably making
about 40 say she's done around twenty
four thousand dollar car makes 40 it's
in Santa
you sell a car that's a real popular
conversation that's gonna go over like a
lead balloon yeah I know okay so here's
the deal dude I'm not gonna participate
in your all's delusion
she bought a car she couldn't afford she
threw a hissy fit and you went along
with it because you were the boyfriend
and you guys got to correct this this is
a real dangerous pattern that's going to
cause you to be broke your whole lives
going forward so if the the correct
financial thing for her to do is to sell
the car the likelihood of her doing it
with the situation you've described to
me is about zero I don't think she'll
ever do that I think you'll ever sorry
and I don't think you'll ever force our
hand that hard but I'm telling you this
whole conversation and how this comes
about the situation you're in is a
danger zone for your future marriage can
you imagine if you replicate this stupid
but decision 20 times in the next 20
years you're going to be broke your
whole life and so that's yeah that's
what you guys got to solve so here's one
Monday I'm gonna pay for both of you as
a wedding gift to go through Financial
Peace University I'm going to give you
the one-year membership and you go to
the nine classes and then you don't
bring up selling the car and you don't
tell her I said to sell the car until
after you've been through the nine
classes and once you've done that if she
doesn't come to that same conclusion
then you guys really need to spend some
time with your pre marriage counselor
because you are about to have a lot of
fights about the number one cause of
divorce in North America today money
fights and money problems because the
last go-round you did not stand up for
what's right and you allowed the woman
you love to do something quite harmful
to herself bad job and you guys got to
fix that pattern so hold on loving your
heart here buddy I hope you feel it but
I think you can do this I'm gonna give
you a financial piece and Kelly's going
to pick up and we're gonna get you
signed up for that thanks for the call